multiple videos and exercises we cover
the various techniques for finding
limits but sometimes it's helpful to
think about strategies for determining
which technique to use and that's what
we're going to cover in this video what
you see here is a flowchart developed by
the team at khan academy and i'm
essentially going to work through that
flowchart it looks a little bit
complicated at first but hopefully it'll
make sense as we talk it through
so the goal is hey we want to find the
limit of f of x as x approaches a
so what this is telling us to do is well
the first thing just try to substitute
what happens when x equals a let's
evaluate f of a
and this flowchart says well if f of a
is equal to a real number it's saying
we're done but then there's this little
caveat here probably and the reason why
is that the limit is a different thing
than the value of the function sometimes
they happen to be the same in fact
that's the definition of a continuous
function which we talked about in
previous videos but sometimes they
aren't the same this will not
necessarily be true if you're dealing
with some function that has a
point discontinuity like that or a jump
discontinuity or a function that looks
like this
this would not necessarily be the case
but if at that point you're trying to
find the limit towards
the if as you approach this point right
over here the function is continuous
it's behaving somewhat normally then
this is a good thing to keep in mind you
could just say hey can i just evaluate
the function at that at that a over
there so in general if you're dealing
with pretty plain vanilla functions like
an x squared or if you're dealing with
rational expressions like this or
trigonometric expressions and if you're
able to just evaluate the function and
it gives you a real number you are
probably done if you're dealing with
some type of a function that has all
sorts of special cases and it's
piecewise defined as we've seen in
previous other videos i would be a
little bit more skeptical or if you know
visually around that point there's some
type of jump or some type of
discontinuity you've got to be a little
bit more careful but in general this is
a pretty good rule of thumb if you're
dealing with plain vanilla functions
that are continuous
if you evaluate at x equals a and you
get a real number that's probably going
to be the limit but now let's think
about the other scenarios what happens
if you evaluate it and you get some
number divided by zero
well that case you are probably dealing
with a vertical asymptote and what do we
mean by a vertical asymptote well look
at this example right over here we're
just saying the limit you do that in a
darker color
so if we're talking about the limit
as x approaches 1 of 1 over
x minus 1. if you just try to evaluate
this expression at x equals 1 you would
get 1 over 1 minus 1 which is equal to 1
over 0 which says okay i'm throwing it
i'm falling into this vertical asymptote
case and at that point if you wanted to
just understand what was going on there
or even verify that it's a vertical
asymptote well then you could try out
some numbers you could try to plot it
you could say all right i probably have
a vertical asymptote here at x equals
one
so that's my vertical asymptote and you
could try out some values well let's see
if x is greater than one the denominator
is going to be positive and so my graph
and you would get this from trying out a
bunch of values might look something
like this and then for values less than
negative one or less than one i should
say you're going to get negative values
and so your graph might look like
something like that and so you have this
vertical asymptote that's probably what
you have now there are cases very
special cases where you won't
necessarily have the vertical asymptote
one example of that would be something
like 1 over x
minus x this one here is actually
undefined for any x you give it so it
would be very you will not have a
vertical asymptote this is a very
special case most times you do have a
vertical asymptote there but let's say
we don't fall into either of those
situations what if when we evaluate the
function we get zero over zero and here
is an example of that limit as x
approaches negative 1 of this rational
expression and let's try to evaluate it
you get negative 1 squared which is 1
minus negative 1 which is plus 1
minus 2 so you get 0 in the numerator
and then in the denominator you have
negative 1 squared which is 1 minus 2
times negative 1 so plus 2
minus 3 which is equal to 0.
now this is known as indeterminate form
and so on our flow chart we then
continue to the right side of it and so
here's a bunch of techniques for trying
to tackle something in indeterminate
form and
likely in a few weeks you will learn
another technique that involves a little
bit more calculus called l'hopital's
rule that we don't tackle here because
that involves calculus while all of
these techniques can be done with things
before calculus some algebraic
techniques and some trigonometric
techniques
so the first thing that you might want
to try to do especially if you're
dealing with a rational expression like
this and you're getting indeterminate
form is try to factor it
try to see if you can simplify this
expression and this expression here you
can factor it this is the same thing as
x let's see x
minus two times x plus one
over
let's see x
would this would be x minus three
times x plus 1. if what i just did seems
completely foreign to you i encourage
you to watch the videos on factoring
factoring polynomials
or factoring quadratics and so
you can see here all right look if if i
make the i can simplify this because as
long as x does not equal negative 1
these two things are going to cancel out
so i can say that this is going to be
equal to x minus 2
over x minus 3
for
x does not equal negative one i
sometimes people forget to do this part
this is if you're really being
mathematically precise this entire
expression is the same as this one
because this entire expression is still
not defined at x equals negative one
although you can substitute x equals
negative one here and now get a value so
if you substitute x equals negative one
here even if it's formally for formally
taking it away to be mathematically
equivalent this would be negative one
minus two which would be
which would be negative 3
over negative 1 minus 3 which would be
negative 4 which is equal to 3 4. so if
this
condition wasn't here you could just
evaluate it straight up and this is a
pretty plain vanilla function
i wouldn't expect to see anything crazy
happening here and if i can just
evaluate it at x equals negative one i
feel pretty good i feel pretty good so
once again we're now going factoring
we're able to factor we evaluate
simplify it we evaluate the expression
the simplified expression now and now we
were able to get a value we were able to
get three-fourths and so we can feel
pretty good that the limit here in this
situation is three-fourths
now let's and i would categorize what
we've seen so far is the bulk of the
limit exercises that you will likely
encounter now the next two i would call
slightly fancier techniques
so if you get indeterminate form
especially you'll sometimes see it with
radical expressions like this rational
radical expressions
you might want to multiply by a
conjugate so for example in this
situation right here if you just tried
to evaluate it x equals 4 you get the
square root of 4 minus 2
over 4 minus 4 which is 0 over 0. so
it's that indeterminate form
and the technique here because we're
seeing this radical and a rational
expression is hey let's maybe maybe we
can somehow get rid of that radical or
simplify it somehow
so let me rewrite it square to x minus 2
over
x
minus 4.
we say a conjugate let's multiply it by
the square root of x plus 2
over the square root of x
plus 2. once again i'm it's the same
expression over the same expression so
i'm not fundamentally changing its value
and so this is going to be equal to well
if i have a plus b times a minus b i'm
going to get a difference of squares so
it's going to be square root of x
squared which is let me just write it's
going to be square root of x squared
minus 4
over well square root of x squared is
just going to be x minus 4. so let me
rewrite it that way
so it's x minus 4
over
x minus 4 times square root of x plus 2
square root of x
plus 2. well this was useful because now
i can cancel out x equals 4 or x minus 4
right over here and once again if i
wanted it mathematically to be the exact
same expression i would say well now
this is going to be equal to
1 over the square root of x plus 2 for x
does not equal 4 but we can definitely
see what this function is approaching if
we just now substitute x equals 4 into
this simplified expression
and so that's just going to be 1 over
so if we just substitute
if we just substitute x equals 4 here
you get 1 over square root of 4
plus 2 which is equal to 1 4. and once
again you can feel pretty good that this
is going to be your limit we've gone
back into the green zone if you were to
actually plot this original function you
would have a a point discontinuity you
would have a gap at x equals
four
but then when you do that simplification
and factoring out that x y or or
canceling out that x minus four that gap
would disappear and so that's
essentially what you're doing you're
trying to find the limit as we approach
that gap which we got already there
now this final one this is dealing with
trig identities and
in order to do these you have to be
pretty pretty adept at your trig
identities so if we're saying the limit
as we do that in a darker color
so if we're saying the limit
as x approaches 0 of sine of x
over sine
of 2x
well sine of zero zero sine zero zero
you're gonna get zero over zero once you
get indeterminate form we've found to
this category and now you might
recognize this is going to be equal to
the limit
as x approaches zero of sine of x
we can rewrite sine of 2x as 2 sine
x cosine x
and then those two can cancel out for
all x's not equaling
for all x's not equaling 0. if you want
to be really mathematically precise
and so
there would have been a gap there for
sure on the original graph if you were
to graph y equals this but now for the
limit purposes you could say this is
this limit
is
this limit is going to be the limit as x
approaches 0
of 1 over 2 cosine of x
and cos and now we can go back to
this green condition right over here
because we can evaluate this at x equals
0. it's going to be 1 over 2 times
cosine of 0 cosine of 0 is 1. so this is
going to be equal to
1 half
now in general none of these techniques
work and you'll encounter a few other
techniques further on once you learn
more calculus then you fall on the
baseline approximation and approximation
you can do it numerically try values
really really really really close to the
number you're trying to find the limit
on you know if you're trying to find the
limit as x approaches zero try zero
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero one try
negative zero point zero zero zero zero
zero zero one if you're trying to find
the limit as x approaches four try four
point zero zero zero zero zero one try
three point nine nine nine nine nine
nine
and see what happens but that's kind of
the last ditch the last ditch effort